check out this story we got from the New
York Post at least two Republican
District Attorneys want to prosecute
bidens according to rep James Comer I
mean that's it he says I had two calls
yesterday one from a county attorney in
Kentucky one from Tennessee they were
they were Republican obviously both
states are heavily Republican they want
to know if there are ways they can go
after the bidens now bring it on just
unleash it yeah every single person who
lives in a conservative District should
be contacting your local prosecutor's
office and saying to them I want you to
indict Barack Obama Joe Biden Hillary
Clinton or all three you pick oh boy
should we go through uh Tom you want to
throw out any random examples of what we
could possibly indict any one of those
three four well I know one of the
brothers for Biden is uh or had been
living in Florida
oh you got Ron DeSantis right there come
on baby yeah you know and well so so I
talked to the New York Post over the
weekend I said all bets are off you're
going to have district attorneys in
Texas and Florida if they're not doing
if they're doing their job they're going
to be thinking what is the hook into the
Biden crime family all right all right
my big thing is I want to see Barack
Obama criminally charged for murder for
the killing of Abdul Rahman al-alaki the
16 year old at the civilian Cafe that
was blown up now Dave Smith mentioned
they'd have to arrest Trump and Bush and
Biden and Clinton and you know and go
back to Bush again for if they're if
they're going after war crimes and
things like that and I'm like well okay
and he agrees but let's let's wind
things back right let's let's go Tit for
Tat they indict Trump on complete bunk
BS
is there anything you've seen in in what
you do that you think is immediately
indictable for the Biden family
oh sure I mean I've interviewed uh Rudy
Giuliani who's a national expert on Rico
uh what you're seeing are the Hallmarks
of a RICO operation and with Biden
running it out of the vice presidency
continuing to benefit from it afterwards
for those that don't know can you break
down Rico well the racketeering
influence corrupt organizations act it's
usually used against the mafia where
family is run and you're kind of engaged
and uh so you're saying 10 for the big
big guy right and uh for instance when
Hunter is complaining that I'm giving
money that I'm earning to Joe
and paying all of his bills and Joe
isn't reporting that I mean that's like
something out of Sopranos right yeah you
know we got to take care of you know the
uncle a parody of The Sopranos yeah well
and and it to me it's so wildly
dangerous because it's a national
security threat I mean we're we're we've
got this Civil War uh mentality here in
the United States these days
unfortunately
think if you're Putin you're thinking of
your chairman of Z looking what's going
on here first of all you know Biden's on
the take
because he's in your back pocket you
have Bobby linski saying he is yeah
you've got the Moscow mayor's uh Widow
oligarch giving money to the Biden
family barisma was a Russian leading
company by the way so they've got that
Ukraine angle and then the Chinese what
I mean 35 million dollars last I check
and money going so they've got him on
the take so does it mean that oh I uh
Biden is is is taking a call from Judy
saying what should I do no but when
you're doing their calculus is how is
the U.S going to react well we do know
Biden's corrupt and he knows we know
he's corrupt because we've got the goods
on him so we're going to do things in a
more aggressive way than we might
otherwise like invade Ukraine or put
extra pressure on Taiwan or send a
spycraft to attack the United States and
do figure eights over our military and
watch him do nothing because we got his
number
because of our corrupt dealings with
them it's what they they claimed Donald
Trump was compromised by Russia or worse
a Soviet asset and and the funny thing
is Russia didn't invade Ukraine while
Trump was president
Russia if they did have compromat on
Donald Trump would have been like what's
he gonna do about it but they didn't
instead when Joe Biden gets in they do
and Biden's is like oh I better just
funnel a whole bunch of money into this
country
I think they know
in this instance it's more about Joe
Biden lacks the wherewithal to actually
lead this country the people around him
also don't have the wherewithal
Afghanistan was a complete disaster and
more importantly that was Trump's fault
are they going to indict him for that
after today yeah they've got the they've
got DC the fed's going after Trump
Georgia they're gonna I think they're
gonna go after Trump on a bunch of
different charges and I think
if I had to make a bet he's going to get
convicted in New York and everyone well
that wouldn't surprise me either and I I
would say every active Republican and
every active conservative and dissident
liberals out there should be worried
about their personal Liberty all bets
are off there's nothing too Petty you've
got these uh political prosecutions all
across the United States
uh you know this this poor guy who got
caught up with the uh immigrant or the
illegal alien on his property right him
uh also this guy who ran into a crowd of
protesters he thought his life was on
the line they're Prosecuting him which
one was that uh this is just in the
paper recently I think cernovich had a
tweet on and I retweeted it do you know
where it was
um I'll check my Twitter let me let me
pull up but keep talking and and then
you had the pro-lifers who were being
targeted by the Biden Administration and
then the January 6 protesters where
they're not just focused on protesters
who beat up a cop or hit a cop over the
head they're going after protesters who
committed misdemeanors by being in a
part of the federal property they
weren't supposed to be parading that's
never been prosecuted this way
so it and what's the basis for I mean
what's the distinction well they're just
Republicans and conservatives I was
there for the Kavanaugh hearings Justice
Kavanaugh I mean I saw I mean it's just
like Tennessee I mean it was violent
people were afraid the left was
intimidating and disrupting proceedings
and they got fifty dollar tickets
so I mean we we've got this uh this
effort where the left and its leadership
in the Democratic party too often
endorse violence now I I don't know any
any I don't know any Republicans out
there in a leadership position
that endorse condone and ratify violence
to you I don't no so I I do know it's
endemic in the left I I do think I have
the story you may have referenced is it
is it this one Daniel Perry is 9-1-1
call played in court
is this the guy who he rode into a car
into a crowd ended up having to kill
someone I don't think he he uh I think
he quote I made a wrong turn a guy
pointed a freaking weapon weapon at me
and I panicked I don't know what to do
I'm just an Uber driver I made a wrong
turn I've never had to shoot someone
before they started shooting back at me
and I got out of the area I'm scared I'm
terrified I'm worried they're going to
go after me I've never had to defend
myself before
they're charging this guy isn't it yep
yep yep and he's accused of murder this
guy they went up to his car just a
regular old Uber driver with what did he
have he had an AK didn't he I don't know
the nature of the weapon he had yeah I'm
sorry man I I said this five years ago I
said you the regular citizen keep
thinking that you will keep your door
closed and keep your lights off and you
will cross your fingers the mob walks
past your home they won't and when they
do fire bomb it and you call 91 and say
For the Love of All That is Holy please
save me they will show up to your house
walk into your house and arrest you for
insulting the mob because two cops can't
deal with a riot but they can deal with
you and if the rioters are screaming and
threatening violence the cops are going
to say well if we don't arrest him
they're going to fire bomb buildings we
may as well just arrest him we saw this
with Dan Dix who is a reporter in Canada
a bunch of far left to start threatening
him and the cops grabbed him and said if
you don't leave we'll arrest you and
he's like what they attacked me and
they're like shut up and leave or you're
under arrest this is only going to get
worse this guy's mind you're an Uber
driver I want you to I want everyone
listen to understand this you're driving
home from the grocery store you picked
up your milk your bread and your eggs
all of a sudden a violent mob of mask
wearing individuals with weapons
surround your car bang on it and one guy
points a gun at your face
defend yourself
now you're in prison attempted murder
and the far left extremists
they're letting out the real criminals
and this wasn't wasn't this in the gulag
archipelago
they're writing about with the criminal
when the criminals caught with a weapon
well it's it's it's a mistake they're
just they don't know better it's in
their nature so we'll take the weapon
from them and say no no you don't do
that again but if you you understand why
you had the weapon you're good you're
going to the gulag right right well and
and you it kind of goes back to the
Rittenhouse prosecution which was
obvious self-defense but you had
politicized prosecutors up there trying
to make an example of him for exercising
not as just his constitutional right to
defend yourself but you're god-given
right to defend yourself I mean this is
we have to recognize these rights that
the left says argue about whether you
know whether the Constitution covers
them or not no the Constitution
recognizes these rights that we had
prior to the Constitution and codifies
them and that goes to the Second
Amendment right and the 14th Amendment
which is also caught caught up with the
Second Amendment people think it's just
the Second Amendment the 14th Amendment
equal protection of the law
and that's not something we're all being
provided right now Trump is having his
civil rights violated six ways to Sunday
equal protection of laws anyone think
that Trump has given the equal
protection of the law with them coming
up with laws that have never been
enforced before or applied in such an
outrageous way against him simply
because of his politics
the terrible times terrible times the
country is uh
I mean
we're in a fifth generational Civil War
and uh I don't know how you can look at
what's going on and think anything else
it is not as the the American Civil War
went with one state being like I have is
a seed another state being like Oh no
you don't no it's various factions of
influence gaining control and what we
have seen consistently over the past
decade is the weaponization of the
office of law to crush
anti-establishment and conservative
individuals and it is escalating and
getting worse every day
when I said this stuff five years ago we
weren't looking at a dude about to go to
prison because black lives matter
pointed a rifle at his face and he's the
bad guy
if you're the victim and you fight back
you go to jail just like that guy in New
York and you know what I think I think
these DA's know they're doing it you
can't have a story like this this Daniel
Perry Guy high profile it's been several
years you can't have a story like that
and then get the story out of New York
where the uh what was the parking garage
attendant gets shot twice right wrestles
The Gun away he doesn't have a gun he
wrestles a gun away from the guy who's
trying to kill him shoots him and he
wakes up handcuffed to a hospital bed
being charged with attempted murder
Bragg knew what he was doing they want
you to know if you dare fight back
against the crime they've created they
will punish you that's right and every
police officer in the nation already
knows that which is why uh there's been
more restrictive policing uh less
policing less aggressive policing
because they know if they get in the
wrong situation and they have to defend
themselves or you get into a situation
where it's disputed uh their use of
force their lives are over so why would
you voluntarily put yourselves in
situations apparel like that and as a
result laws go unenforced and the bad
guys win and I don't mean ideologically
the bad guys they do win because they
support Insurrection and crime because
it helps build the revolution but the
bad guys who who victimize cities in the
criminal traditional sense are are
running rampant right now in Washington
DC every major city
crime crime is is is
impairing significantly uh people's
right to live safely we just said that
story about um that guy what do they
call them crazy Bob I think is his
nickname was yeah founder co-founder of
cash app and square yeah he leaves San
Francisco because of how bad it's
getting and moves to Miami
goes back to SF for a business trip
2 30 in the morning murdered in the
street
was it in the morning I thought it was
the middle of the afternoon was it I
thought it was 2 30 a.m it was an
evening yeah and yet the scary thing is
he took two two two stabs to the chest
and then apparently there's surveillance
footage showing him holding his chest
walking around begging for help and he
goes to a car and lifts his shirt up and
begs for help before dropping dead he
called 9-1-1 and was like begging for
help you know what you know what what
worries me about this is I'm wondering
if he if he died because they he
punctured his lungs and he didn't know
how to protect himself from a chest
sucking list yeah yeah I don't well how
many people would I mean I'm not going
to pretend to be an EMT or anything but
it's not like you have plastic wrap or
anything but my understanding is you can
just Jam your fingers and in a create a
vacuum to keep yourself breathing I
don't know I'm not gonna pretend to know
I'm just saying and you never know how
you react in that scenario well I mean
well you know who who and and I'm not
and I'm not making fun of your point but
what sort of insanity that we would talk
seriously about having Mass training wow
I'm from I'm from Chicago so like when I
was a kid I was told what to do if
someone's suffering a chest sucking
wound and they they explain to us you
take a piece of plastic wrap or any kind
of plastic and you tape it down on three
sides to create a vent so when someone
inhales it actually closes the cavity
and forces air out of the wound so they
can keep breathing yeah and then I don't
know it's like a diaphragm of some type
yeah I don't know if jamming your finger
in the wound to create a seal would work
as well but to keep you alive
temporarily because when you get a CH
when you puncture a lung when you inhale
air doesn't actually move in or out so
you're not getting air and you don't
know it feels like you're breathing but
nothing's actually happening and then
you die so I I hope that's not the case
but anyway I digress this is what's
happening in our cities friends
I doubt there will be any justice there
and my understanding is this guy was was
wealthy and Powerful right he wasn't he
was a tech bro he was a tech Mogul guy
founder of square squares worth a lot of
money and cash app yeah yeah he knew
stabbed outside his like luxury
apartment building right yeah yeah I
mean it was it was in the middle of a it
wasn't like a tough area of San
Francisco was it I think all of San
Francisco is a tough area now no that is
yeah it's crazy and uh so there was
another story
I don't know much about it but uh I was
talking about the other day because I'm
hanging out at the poker tables at
Maryland Live casino and the guy on my
left told me his buddy starts talking
about politics someone mentions like
money someone mentions the economy he
says Ah Joe Biden gets mad and then he
mentions a buddy of his in 2020 was
driving with this girl in a pickup truck
when they get surrounded by BLM who are
banging on his car
so he hits the gas runs some people over
they chase him down he calls 9-1-1 he
just got convicted of attempted murder I
don't know the full details of the story
I looked at the guy's name there's no
news coverage of this and it got me
thinking we've seen stories like Daniel
Perry's where he's an Uber driver
confused right we saw the story out of
Provo Utah where a guy's driving his
truck BLM runs up and just shoots the
guy for no reason shoots a guy I think
she shot a guy in the arm I bet it might
have been a woman
how many of those stories have also
happened where there was no video
footage and so we've not heard anything
so when I looked up this story of this
guy what did I find the media just says
he ran over a bicyclist that's it
there's nothing else because there's no
footage showing black lives matter
antifa trying to kill him or his
girlfriend
and on top of that we have this uh
this kind of craziness with the
transgender extremism which is
obviously a violent movement uh it's a
tool of the left of course thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time